qué posibilidades de éxito ven a esta
nueva mesa de diálogo el gobierno está
en capacidad de cumplir las exigencias
que ustedes plantean
nosotros consideramos que el gobierno
tiene todas las posibilidades de dar fin
a esta protesta social siempre y cuando
su actitud sea de compromiso de con cada
uno de los puntos que se han planteado
en la agenda sobre todo el compromiso de
bajar el costo de la vida de la canasta
básica familiar en panamá las
estadísticas acabamos de sustentar los
movimientos sociales en la mesa que
inició hoy en la mesa única de todo el
movimiento social con el gobierno
facilitada por la iglesia católica en
panamá 600.000 panameños se acuestan a
dormir sin tener una comida al día y en
la canasta básica para poder sufragar
con todos los nutrientes y todas las
facilidades que se deben tener para
vivir una vida justa digna y plena y
feliz es de casi 1600 valuadas cuando
aquí el salario mínimo de un trabajador
panameño que tiene trabajo formal es de
600 balboas
situación que no le alcanza siquiera
para lo que sería subsistir la quincena
de cada personas de la canasta básica de
alimentos para entonces decir que pueda
tener el acceso a otros a otros recursos
oa otras formas de vida qué pasa si no
hay acuerdo continuarán las protestas
pese a estas pérdidas millonarias que se
han producido
y nosotros consideramos que el gobierno
tiene que hacer las concesiones
a por el pueblo consideramos que el
gobierno y la clase que está gobernando
están entendiendo que tienen que hacer
los cambios al modelo económico e
impuestos desde el año 1990 que es un
modelo de
neoliberal que ha profundizado la
desigualdad social que ha profundizado
la falta de equidad y que esto para
poder salir de la crisis tanto el
gobierno como los sectores sociales
tenemos que llegar a punto de acuerdo
señor herrera cuál es la situación que
viven los panameños en este momento
cuáles son los productos y servicios que
más se han encarecido
bueno el costo del combustible el alto
costo del combustible el ascenso en los
precios por galón llevó a un alza
desmedida de la canasta básica de
alimentos y también pues el tema un tema
que también ayuda ha ayudado para que
esta situación social sea más difícil en
este momento el el alto costo de los
medicamentos y el acceso a la salud en
panamá entonces esto estos factores han
llevado a que la población se mantenga
en las calles miren que ya bajaron el
costo gracias a las primeras
negociaciones del combustible de 6 valúa
a 325 y esto no nos logro pues bajar un
poco el ánimo de la población